todos sonhamos
eu sonhei em fazer o curso eu sempre me
interessei por erro e conseguir eu
sonhei um sonho de ser mãe eu tive a
minha primeira filha mas foi o
conhecimento da minha segunda filha do
meu percurso de vida mudou desde o
primeiro momento eu senti que a minha
filha era diferente
toda mulher tem um sexto sentido eu
tenho os médicos não sabiam dizer o que
a minha filha tinha eu achei que
deveríamos ouvir outras opiniões fora do
país
vamos à áfrica do sul daniels vitor
depois de alguns exames disseram que a
minha filha tinha a hipotonia em
português significa fraqueza muscular
mas da minha filha era grave e
generalizada
eu não fiquei satisfeita com o que o
diagnóstico porque eu achava que se eu
tivesse lutar pela minha filha
o inimigo teria que se revelar pensei em
procurar outros apoios ainda mais
distante e fomos a portugal
a minha filha deva ser atendida por um
centro que cuida de crianças com
deficiência
quando souberam do diagnóstico eles
pediram a intervenção de uma médica
especialista
depois dos 15 minutos o américa tinha um
diagnóstico ela disse que a minha filha
tinha síndrome de angelman que é uma
doença área a cada 20 mil nascimentos só
uma criança é que é afetada sair daquela
consulta turista
eu não conseguia dormir por uma
pesquisar
primeiro o que são doenças raras eu
nunca tinha ouvido falar de doenças
raras na minha vida
e depois o que este tal daniel - eu
entrei para as características eu não
quis acreditar
minha filha tinha 90% das
características num belo dia eu estava a
ver televisão estava a falar do centro
no norte de portugal que tratavam das
doenças raras tenham alguns tratamentos
inovadores
eu contei aqui é o centro e eles
mostraram disponíveis para trabalhar com
a minha filha
nós mudamos para o nota isso implicou
também a mudança do método
na primeira consulta médica que saber o
que é que a minha filha tinha eu disse
que era assim não tenham medo é melhor
que a minha filha e disse não não é sem
dúvida o momento entretanto vocês podem
imaginar o meu desespero eu estava
habituado ao ángel mena e afinal podia
não ser ficarmos dez meses à espera dos
resultados vieram à final
a minha filha tem a síndrome direto que
é uma doença área a cada 15 mil
nascimentos só uma criança é que é
afetada exclusiva do sexo feminino já
tínhamos um inimigo não estava muito se
não voltar a moçambique e eu só qual
seria a melhor arma para combater aquele
inimigo o amor
nós fomos felizes durante os três anos e
meio que a minha filha estava entre nós
seu desaparecimento físico causou raiva
foi injusto
depois de tudo que nós passamos não era
suposto a minha filha a sair também mas
olhei para aquilo e eu pensei que a
minha filha também estivesse a dar uma
missão talvez ela quisesse que olhar por
esse lado da sociedade escondido e isso
deu-me força
eu me luz pra entrar para o mundo da
deficiência
eu passei a ler mais sobre doenças raras
para se informar
eu soube que existem cerca de 7 mil
destas doenças em outros países já
existem as exceções para algumas destas
doenças
eu olhei pro casos ambicano eu vi que
estamos aquém do desejado para jamor nem
sequer falamos dessas destas doenças
nós só temos uma criança com deficiência
nos braços o que está por trás dessa
deficiência é praticamente inexplorado e
isso faz com que abra espaço para o
obscurantismo
vou contar a história da minha amiguinha
machine lá
a china tem 13 anos de idade
a china não anda não fala e não vê mas é
das crianças mais felizes que alguma vez
conheci na minha vida o pai da china
abandonou por este motivo a mãe tentou
uma ação de pensão de alimentos
o tribunal em plena audiência o pai da
chinela disso que não paga a pensão de
alimentos por consultou uma curandeira e
a curandeira disse que aquela filha não
era dele
a deficiência o abandono ausência de
diagnósticos estão muitas vezes
interligados no nosso contexto e nós nós
mulheres somos acusadas por ter uma
criança com deficiência significa
adultério
nós nunca exploramos por exemplo
questões genéticas
eu olhei para o meu caso eu considerei
me sortuda eu pensei em outras famílias
que estão a passar por situação
semelhante à minha e eu só tenho a
certeza de uma coisa que eu iria
trabalhar contra as mulheres e que
tivessem crianças com deficiência
eu juntei um grupo de mulheres
nós criamos a cooperativa no ano nas
meias o riso
o nosso objetivo é lutar pelos direitos
dos nossos filhos e por as doenças
várias na agenda governamental
nós apoiamos 34 crianças
[Aplausos]
nós apoiamos 34 crianças são crianças
com múltiplas deficiências
algumas mais leves e outras mais severas
destas 34 crianças nenhuma tem
diagnóstico e nós temos casos
repetitivos a nível das famílias
o nosso trabalho o nosso trabalho
eu não podia terminar o trabalho é
baseado em solidariedade é baseado entre
ajuda e somos nós
mais de crianças com deficiência a
cuidar mas não só dos nossos filhos mas
também das crianças do bairro quando nós
estamos localizados
vou partilhar uma outra história do meu
amiguinho o davis quando eu recebi desde
na cooperativa eu dizia por aí umas
cinco palavras
hoje está com 30 palavras mas esta é uma
outra história
os vizinhos do davis não deixava que os
filhos brincarem com 10 porque o pai
dele é deficiente e pensaram que o deixe
de se contaminar os filhos nos dirigimos
à casa do estudo desde temos uma
palestra explicando seus vizinhos a
condição do davis nós temos que nos
transmite a pelo contato físico
depois de um ano numa bela manhã a mãe
do deivid entrou na cooperativa e ela
vem ter comigo e sabe mãe de neuza os
meus vizinhos já pedem aos filhos para
irem brincar godês e olhei pra isso como
uma vitória do desafio as pessoas podem
mudar sim as pessoas podem mudar e eu
tenho a certeza
tenha certeza que um dia as nossas
crianças não mais serão rejeitadas em
transportes públicos por terem uma
cadeira de rodas
um dia as nossas crianças não mais serão
rejeitadas em escolas públicas por não
terem professores capacitados para
trabalhar
com elas um dia as nossas crianças não
mais serão encaminhadas da casa dá
polimento pelos seus familiares por se
envergonhar e suas deficiências e um dia
um dia nós vamos ter uma base de dados
de doenças raras diagnosticadas aqui é
uns amigos porque nós
nós acreditamos que é normal ser
especial e nesta caminhada eu não quero
fazer sozinha eu quero fazer com cada um
de vocês porque a deficiência nos amigos
a deficiência no centro na pel a
deficiência senta aqui no coração
[Música]